[Musique]
le préfet des yvelines a réuni le 28
juillet dernier le comité départemental
de la ressource en eau pour faire un
point sur la situation des cours d'eau
et des nappes phréatiques et a décidé de
placer le sud du département en alerte
renforcée et de maintenir le nord du
département en vigilance
la partie sud concernés par l'alerté
renforcé par à l'ouest deux environ la
commune de graisser jusqu à vélizy
villacoublay à l'est du département et
tout au nord de cette ligne donc la mode
la vaucouleurs la scène reste en
vigilance
[Musique]
cette décision est en application à
partir du 30 juillet c'est par exemple
l'interdiction de remplissage des
piscines
l'interdiction d'arrosage des trottoirs
l'interdiction d'arrosage la journée des
jardins des mesures d'interdiction qui
sont obligatoires concerne le dispositif
d'alerté renforcée dans le sud yvelines
la moitié sud yvelines dans le sud des
yvelines nous avons beaucoup de têtes de
bassin versant c'est-à-dire de source de
nombreuses rivières qui sont très
sensibles à la sécheresse
et nous avons aussi un suivi météo qui
nous a été fait avec des prévisions qui
n'annonce pas de pluie marquante dans
les jours qui viennent également
l'office français de la biodiversité qui
est allé constater sur le terrain le
niveau des rivières avec des rivières
qui sont déjà à sec dans le sud des
yvelines